l'aventuré était en sable et rebaptisé 1
était en maison de quartier cette
initiative a été mise en place pour
combler les vacances des enfants ne
pouvant pas partir en les accueillant à
la maison de quartier jouvet à montigny
le bretonneux
le dispositif 1 était en maison de
quartier et cet été réservé aux animaux
atteints l'événement associe des trois
maisons de quartiers de la ville
ne pouvant pas faire l'été en sable
comme les années passées nous avons mis
en place l'été en maison de quartier de
manière à promouvoir un petit peu les
activités qui sont faites dans les
maisons de quartier et d'offrir aux unis
montrent un des activités ludiques
créatives et steve à la dans chacun des
lieux une limite de 15 personnes a été
fixé pour chaque atelier assurant le
respect des gestes-barrières sous la
responsabilité des parents présents sur
place une vingtaine d'activités est
proposée à la maison de quartier jouvet
au programme peinture atelier
scientifique ou encore créatif est en
train de faire des hélicoptères et une
vieille et un dossier pour mon dernier
tuto et tout après on va les essayer en
effet un volet ce que j'adore russie et
que je et qu'on ne retrouve pas par
contre aller dans saab sas côte est
vraiment très lié avec les familles où
on est là pour les familles on est là
pour leur donner des billes on est là
pour les aider on est là pour les
écouter
la ville espère pour l'été prochain un
retour à la normale avec une reprise des
thés en sable